hmm
mechanically
I just put my arm in there and throw him
down because I decide when that stop
should be
spiritually
I would let it come to its fruition and
he would fall down when the energies
stopped
all right so so that's why we need to
break down each piece and sort of like
go well this is hard work isn't it it's
easier like that well this is the hard
work without you going nine years of
training so this is the best you can do
well I've got that now
gosh okay I've got to turn it we're on
the coat of guys I've actually got a
crank it a little more
all right so we're adding to the same so
it's all about hand shapes
and this was brought about by watching a
Ukrainian soldier on the front line
trying to huge thank you trying to humor
his um
mates and he was got a pack of cards and
he was going like that pick a card they
picked a card and he shuffled it and he
was doing in Mylanta and he said uh that
one they go no he goes are you sure and
he shakes it and it changes to the card
that he it was
so it made me realize that in Aikido we
don't actually realize how you have to
be
quick with your hands
and what you how you shape them right so
so anyhow Okay so